now a parliamentary vote on Trident has
long been on the cards but a date still
hasn't actually been set for one it's a
divisive issue within the labour party
especially with Jeremy Corbyn its leader
firmly opposed to renewing Britain's
nuclear deterrent and now the Prime
Minister has been urged not by party
politics with the timing of the vote by
a senior member of his own party and
that man is with me now Annie's Julian
Lewis chair of the influential defence
Select Committee in a very good morning
- mr. Lewis party politics with this
issue well it's quite simple and that is
that everybody is ready for this debate
and vote to go ahead the Labour
moderates wanted to go ahead the Labour
Left led by Jeremy Corbyn have never
been afraid to debate this subject the
SNP wanted to go ahead conservative Pro
tried and MPs which is the overwhelming
majority wanted to go ahead and the only
thing that appears to be standing
between the vote and the carrying
forward of the policy is number 10
Downing Street and I think the Prime
Minister really has to intervene I know
he's got a lot on his mind what are you
saying is their calculation then why
would they want to delay I mean there as
you've described as I've described there
is that difference of opinion to say the
very least within the labour party why
would they want to wait well the answer
is this later this year labour will have
its party conference in October of
course and they will then decide whether
to change their position which still
remains a multilateral approach to
nuclear disarmament rather than a
one-sided disarmament approach to the
issue they will decide whether to change
that and go back to the days when they
supported the campaign for nuclear
disarmament and one-sided disarmament
and I can only assume that the reason
for this overdue vote being delayed
until then is that some of the so-called
strategists who advised the prime
minister are suggesting that it would be
better for labour to impale themselves
further on the hook as you see them
becoming unilateral by voting having the
debate and voting within the conference
then along comes the government with
this issue in the House of Commons yes I
mean the fact is it would probably
strengthen the hand of the moderates in
the labour party who support Trident and
there are many Labour MPs who support
Trident just as strongly as conservative
ones do it would strengthen their hands
if the vote was done and dusted before
the conference because they then be able
to say let's not go back to what general
kaufman famously called the longest
suicide note in history in 1983 an
accusation for you to be making about
the nasa call all the way to talk about
the prime minister this is about the
defense of the realm for goodness sake
and you're saying playing politics with
it well I'm I'm saying that I want the
prime minister to take control of the
people who are perhaps and badly
advising him but it wouldn't be the
first time that we've had a situation of
this sort because in October 2010 purely
as what I described at the time a love
gift to the Liberal Democrats the
conservative leadership agreed to extend
the life of the existing Trident
submarines by at least five years until
after the general election now that was
a terrible and unforgiveable decision
because everybody expected there to be
another hung parliament if there had
been another hung parliament even though
the overwhelming majority of
conservative and Labour MPs support the
renewal of the deterrent the Liberal
Democrats could have played off one
leader against another and said unless
you get rid of this one system I won't
give you the keys to down a thank
goodness that didn't transpire but if he
easily could have done so the fact is
party politics has been riddling its way
through this whole debate and it should
we've no doubt about which way you have
hurt in that debate if and when it comes
and just related to current events and
I'm thinking obviously with reference to
North Korea and you know why nuclear
deterrents are still required yes I mean
and even if North Korea weren't rattling
the nuclear bars of its cage
it would still be the case that what
we're doing here is taking a decision
not just for the political military
strategic situation that can
Frances now but for the next 30 40 and
50 years that is the lifespan of this
weapon system and we cannot possibly
predict what threats will arise over
that period and just as it make sense to
have adequate conventional forces in
peacetime so it is the ultimate
insurance policy to have a minimum
strategic nuclear deterrent such as
Trident
when we don't know what threats are
waiting for us in the next 20 30 or 40
years okay and a quick thought while you
with us mr. Lewis about your your
constituency Association several low are
quite a few dozen have actually written
saying they they feel slighted by the
prime minister after all their efforts
during the general election campaign he
stood up in the house of commons and
said when it comes to the EU issue when
it comes to any new referendum don't
listen mp's don't listen to your
constituency associations you know you
make up your own mind
well my constituency Association I
believe selected me in February 1996
long time ago primarily because of the
shortest answer I have ever given to a
political question
and that was I was asked in the
selection meeting would you vote to
replace the pound with the single
European currency and my answer was over
my dead body and that is the the view of
me and it is the view of the majority of
members of my association that the
European Federalist super state project
is something that must be resisted at
all this onus on the statements on these
words is used in the House of Commons do
you think he's had been at the very
least well then just a bit thoughtless a
bit in elegance to tell you the truth I
wasn't able to be present for his
statement so I didn't hear it
word-for-word but what I would say is
this the argument about an emergency
break on the payment of benefits to
people who come to this country from
other European countries seeking work is
to my mind a total distraction and
irrelevance I've got a very short list
of six good reasons why we should vote
to leave the EU and you're not gonna let
me that but that does
even feature you still just have an
answer the direct question is your
constituency association cross about the
way the Prime Minister spoke
the answer is I haven't had a chance to
ask them then they haven't signed this
letter I don't know if they are asked
but one thing I do know is that the
overwhelming majority of them will be
voting to come out of the EU as should
we all